[Music]
welcome back for a brand new tip 2019
interview very excited about this one
it's for a documentary called there's
something in the water I've got the team
behind the film right here I have a ton
of questions for you guys we have
limited time jumping right into it and I
want to know what's it like having
someone approach you that wants to adapt
your book into a movie because does
anything go through your head where
you're like okay this sounds like a good
idea but only if you respect like this
this and this and do these things
justice well I mean this is amazing and
it's I'm still shocked by it all
it certainly wasn't planned starting in
2016 and you know I did it because I was
passionate about the topic didn't think
any of this would happen so it has been
incredibly exciting to have this
platform and to have Ellen Page and ovis
Koshien bring this to the masses and Ian
Daniel the work he did getting this
together so quickly for TIFF has been
incredible so it's very very exciting I
was wondering if one of you could take a
quick moment to just give a definition
of environmental racism for anyone who's
watching out there who hasn't seen your
movie and might not know what that super
important topic is it's the
disproportionate citing or location of
toxic industries and communities of
color indigenous communities and the
working poor so the notion that
communities that are more invisible
perhaps in many ways more less powerful
lacking in access to economic and
political resources there's a tendency
to place industries and their
communities because they can't fight
back or they're voiceless in certain
ways so that's the typical definition of
environmental racism so I know this may
sound like a silly question because I do
know that there there are abundance of
reasons out there why someone can't do
this but for anyone who hears something
about like these types of situations and
their knee-jerk response is well why
didn't you just move what would you say
to those people
you ever get it and people ask you that
yes they have said that to me why don't
they just move that that students say
that to me stand up in the lecture hall
and say they can why don't they just
move but they don't want to move because
these are their homes and their
communities so the issue is not about
whether or not they should move but
questioning and kind of interrogating
why government tends to place industries
in their area as opposed to other areas
so once again people have to remember
that these are communities historic
communities in many cases who have been
there all their lives they have families
there they love where they live there
are various problems that they have one
being environmental racism but why
should they move they shouldn't yes
from the filmmaking perspective here to
questions that have been on my mind what
is it like trying to figure out when to
incorporate yourselves into the piece
there was just one particular moment
where I think what was the line Oh
someone asks how how would you cope with
this and I think in my mind I
automatically responded to the answer
but neither the question but neither of
you did so I'm just curious what is it
like figuring out when to you know
continue that conversation and once
leave it to the subject I mean we made a
very conscious choice I think it's what
we focused on mostly as we were making
it and then particularly made the
decision in the Edit where and this is
what we wanted the whole time we wanted
the film really truly just to be an
opportunity for these women to speak to
just be heard to say exactly what they
wanted to say and exactly how this has
impacted their lives and their
communities lives and so it was about
that's really how we wanted to structure
the film and structure it stylistically
so you know you have this experience of
going on this journey or seeing someone
you you know recognize go home and take
you on this you know this this journey
around three to three towns in this
province but ultimately we wanted to
have it really just just be about the
women and the people in the film what
about the the running time of the movie
they actually in the interview before us
happened to have been talking about a
movie that was exceptionally long and I
know the second we see I don't know a 70
minute runtime versus a two and a half
hour
or runtime you immediately make
assumptions about a movie so why was I
think it's a 70 plus a little bit why
was that the proper amount of time to
convey these points I don't know what
the I guess I don't know what the
assumption is about the film of it's 70
minutes I think
short and sweet to the point is the you
know how much we chose you know the way
we selected what would what would happen
in the film in the end was it just
became really clear that the women were
leading and their communities and and
the women had been fighting for so long
they had been speaking about these
issues so powerfully already that let's
just bring that to the platform let's
bring it to the table and so we just had
all the we had these three towns and
these three stories that we thought told
this told the told our thesis and our
idea the most powerfully and that's what
we chose and we just you know whatever
amount of time it took to get the story
across and let the women really speak is
the time that ended up being I mean for
us I think I feel very confident in the
71 minutes that we we we let everyone be
heard that we we get our point across
pretty clearly and that there's a
journey in hand that has impact and has
an arc to it turning this into a review
I agree exactly how you described it
Ellen I loved watching you kind of grow
behind the lens also so after this
experience having your first feature
debut under your belt as a director is
getting behind the camera something you
want to do more is a narrative feature
as a director in your future being
behind the camera for sure more I'd love
to continue to direct and make
documentaries I don't really have as
much interest in doing something
narrative fiction I I mostly watch and
pretty much only read nonfiction that
tends to be where and I love making
vacation within which we plan to
continue to do so I hope to continue to
this I do this and I hope to continue to
collaborate with with what I'm hoping I
can always continue to collaborate with
the end because I I really get so much
joy and fulfillment working with him
what is it about for each of you what is
it about the other one that
says to you this is a special because
it's very unique to find that special
collaborator that you never want to
leave that maybe brings something out of
you that you might not have expected so
what is it about each of you that makes
you say that is the person I mean I I
think that Ellen has a great passion for
things you know and very specific thing
so when Ellen speaks about something
over and over again and feels very fired
up about it I start okay
she's that fired up about it I better
get behind it so there's something I
just feel very educated by her passions
you know sometimes I didn't know that
much about environmental racism in terms
of the terms and how it's impacting
areas so Ellen continued to talk to me
about it and I think that that got me
fired up and I said on the other end
totally you know very educated very very
aware of the issues and empower to speak
about it myself there's that in our
collaboration and and I just think that
we just have different ways of looking
at the world and different ways of
dissecting things and Ellen's maybe more
politically driven and in some ways that
I'm not and that's I think a good
friendship and a great partnership is
one that is creatively collaborative but
also challenging and it an educational a
lot of similar things and I think it has
so much to do with honesty you know I
feel like Ian as someone who's
incredibly honest and and sincere and
and I think to be able to have that and
have that back-and-forth and to be able
to have the difficult conversations and
to be able to grow together and to not
be afraid to do that and to to be close
with someone who has that level of
compassion and kindness it's it really
creates I think a wonderful foundation
for being able to work on projects like
this you know absolutely one question
that I had for you specifically because
I I asked this in a lot of a lot of
interviews it's an important question to
me and you are on my list for this
answer who is someone in the film
industry that you think is changing it
for the better
oh goodness good I mean there's there's
there's so many people who are I would I
would I mean I think of someone like Ava
Duvernay when I think of someone who's
you know creating not only incredible
work but creating you know access and
and for for so many people and and I you
know I could go on and on yeah that's
what immediately popped into my head and
just to wrap this up here given the
subject matter we're talking about right
now for somebody out there that is
inspired and wants to do something to
make a difference right now what would
you suggest they go out and do today I
would say that they should connect with
communities they should connect with
communities that are impacted by this
issue form authentic organic
relationships with these communities
allow these communities to drive the
projects to be in the driver's seat but
the first step is always to connect with
the people most impacted and to ask them
what they think they should do to help
so always being driven by the people
impacted thank you guys so much for your
time today there's something in the
water do keep an eye out for it also
before we say goodbye a huge thanks to
our sponsors Nordstrom Canada for making
these interviews happen like and share
this video and stay tuned for more
coverage from TIFF 2019